Triumph comes out of this You Know
sketch doing on the show and you you
come in with this dog whose Talent is
he's an insult comic yes and then I
think what we have to do which I have to
give you credit for is uh two things the
choice of the puppet is exceptional and
and and and I like I say the fact that
the puppets has kind of a realistic face
but the eyes are the eyes are dead and
so he says these jokes and stares and I
think
not unlike why I often found Norm
McDonald so funny is Norm could make his
eyes go dead and and just kind of stare
at you after he said a joke and I do
think that Triumph has that I look into
those puppet eyes and I can watch it
forever but the other thing yeah is the
voice because anybody else doing it who
had that idea of oh yeah it's a dog
who's an insult comic would have done
borch belt hey you over there what do
you suck you know Armenia hey what
Armenia is that even a country sounds
like a kind of diarrhea you know what
what that's a good one Le no don't write
it down yeah it's really goodenia
diarrhea of yeah but anyway what I'm
saying is that's what anybody else would
have done Robert is the only person I
know who would have done I think it's an
old Russian Jewish woman am I correct I
had grandparents that were first
generation immigrants you know who who
escaped Russia during and they actually
immigrated to China first uh to be so
proud of what you've done they they we
must escape persecution so that so
Robert future Generations may be able to
watch to witness a realistic looking
puppet have sex with a live
animal on television and she's like yes
oh yes yes what is this television well
it's going to be a thing in starting
with Milt and
Bur trying to kill us but if we can
escape then one maybe one of our
grandchild our grandchildren contribute
will turn us into a honey puppet the
world yeah I have to credit I have to
credit my wife so because she's the one
who so I found Triumph on this rack of
whimsical puppets that were when we were
shooting when we were newlyweds and we
were hunting for furniture at a country
store and we saw this and the puppet was
so funny to me these dog puppets and
there was a sheep and a cat so I
immediately put on one of the dog
puppets sniffed her ass with it in the
in the room in the in the furniture
store and of course she found it funny
because she's the perfect woman for me
and then she surprised me like in
February like two months later after we
were married with like seven of these
puppets and that's what gave me the idea
for this Westminster thing and like Dave
was having Westminster dogs run up and
down the aisles of the edsen theater
very Dave very found humor and I was
like so our version of that our version
is make it up y yeah so that's um well
so I remember that that that and then I
remember early on before there were
remotes we'd have guests on and Triumph
would roast them and we like catharsis
for the audience yeah and and and so
Triumph would be over behind this little
stand and then and and I would have
interviewed the guest already and then
they go after the guest and I'll never
forget guests would say yes to it not
knowing what it was Simon
is on it's the height of uh the first
couple years of American the first year
of American ID he was like the biggest
thing he was huge he was huge and he
comes on the show and we said do you
mind and he went oh no you know please
whatever whatever these you chaps do go
ahead I'll just be here with my two
tight t-shirt and um and so uh I
interview him it goes you know we have a
nice interview and then we come back and
I go oh look there's someone here to say
hi to you uh Simon you know and then you
come on and you he doesn't know what's
happening you rip into him and he's
chuckling the crowd's going crazy
laughing cuz this is the beginning of
Triumph Mania the crowd's going crazy
laughing you're ripping into him and
he's watching and then when it's over I
say we'll take a break we'll be right
back and he turns to me and he's covered
in sweat he was covered in sweat and he
said that was
rough and I like a guy who had just been
beaten with a stick so funny and then
later I saw him afterward and I was like
was that okay and he he had come to
understand by then he was like no this
is uh this would be good for me and some
way would be able to show that I can
laugh at my and blood came out of his a
tear with blood in it but uh then it was
really fun because
before before the remotes that Triumph
did he was already it people sitting
there and so it was you know all these
great people would sit there and and
this puppet would go out great people
well please yeah at the time Tes yeah um
I love John Tesh I love him too I'll go
to the map for John Tes but but anyway
you would go after him and then yes what
you go to do a remote Westminster dog
show and of course CH I think chilm goes
with you no it was that the first one
was was Jordan and we couldn't get in
first apparently Andy had done something
at Westminster that they didn't like so
they weren't going to let us in and I
was like okay I guess we'll never do it
and and if I done it maybe I would have
never done a remote because that was the
obvious one to do it was Sweeny
suggested why don't you go to West and
hit on these dogs yeah and uh real dogs
yeah because i' had been well i' been
sort of doing it on the show but here's
all these dogs and I loved it but so
then Jordan like creates this scam like
we gave us he printed out all these fake
NBC pass BR law he broke the law and he
figured out a side entrance and he said
it's not technically um it's not
technically deception because we
actually are NBC employees you know it's
very Jordan rationalization yes but it
we got in and it's all because of him
that these remotes exist we tip we tip
our cap now to a man I uh professionally
loathe uh I've made a career a fifth
career out of uh being irritated by
Jordan schlansky but um but no in in
real life he saved the day and then you
know remotes come fast and fu ious and
then the iconic crazy Star Wars remote
where there's not there's not a there's
so many and I remembered it was all
still again before the internet like
things couldn't go viral but I remember
the night we played that the audience
screaming and going wild and thinking
this if there's only some way this can
be replayed for everybody throughout all
time and fortunately now there is no but
actually it was the first thing on the
show that did because before YouTube
there was something called iilm bler
will know this because he's pathetic
nerd right yes that's true okay perfect
I remember this too I watched this over
and over and over iilm and they created
the term viral video too I know that
yeah yeah and um so it that's that is
why everybody even knew it back then it
was the first thing on the show that
that was like put on I film or whatever
it was called and um it was the happiest
experience I ever had doing Triumph
because everybody was like I don't
really like making people unhappy I know
it's good television sometimes
especially if it's like a person nobody
likes but it's so much more fun these
guys were fans of you yeah and they knew
who Triumph was it was like they wanted
to meet Triumph and it was like when I
met Don Rickles what makes it so nice is
that because I'm the same way if I think
I've hurt someone's feelings I don't
sleep for like two days if I think they
really got you know and so um I'm just
saying that to appear nice but you must
never sleep I sleep like a baby no you
know how he solved that it was like an
aversion therapy he decided to be mean
to everybody and that way he he got numb
to yeah yeah my little my son I'm just
everybody and so um but I think the
magic of that was all the people in line
who you're making fun of for being never
seeing a woman or you know what button
do you push to have your mother come
pick you up whatever all they're all all
loving it and and and that's the key is
and they're just delighted and now
they're part of History they're like the
funniest straight men that you could ask
for and the fact that they're enjoying
it just made it like just a
mutual pooper and poopie United as
[Laughter]
one